three years ago Lena started a personal
fitness journey launching a YouTube
channel to bring the world with her her
Channel features workout routines
wedding days fitness tips and some Vlogs
about life as a student in New York City
but alas it seems that no Fitness
influencers content catalog would be
complete without the obligatory cheat
day video no matter how much I love a
Creator I just cannot get behind
glamorizing a cheap day so let's take a
look at how Lena allegedly eats when she
cheats and unpack it safely together hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we'll be taking a look at Fitness
influencer Lena lifts and you can pause
the screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating as always please feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you are not
already subscribed here hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
follow me on Tick Tock and Instagram at
Abby's kitchen okay before we get too
into the video let me tell you about my
sponsor Coco via you might have heard
the great debate on whether chocolate is
good for you or not the truth is cocoa
beans are rich in flavonols which are
clinically proven to support heart
health but in making chocolate the
standard cocoa processing destroys
flavinols the last two years have been a
turning point on flavinol Research so
much so that the Academy of nutrition
and dietetics is now recommending that
adults aim for at least 400 to 600
milligrams of flavinols a day and while
chocolate berries apples and why not
even a little red wine can help it's
hard to reach those recommended levels
consistently every day with our busy
lives so I've been loving Coco via's
cardio Health powders and capsules and
I'm going to show you how to use it to
make a heart-healthy balanced breakfast
that is festive and super tasty we've
got oatmeal yogurt Chia milk and maple
syrup plus a scoop of Coco via's
chocolate flavored cardio Health powder
so I let this sit overnight and I top it
off with some crushed candy canes and
chocolate chips for a festive touch this
contains 500 milligrams of cocoa
flavonols and three grams of O fiber
which helps to support healthy
cholesterol levels and support blood
flow within two hours their supplements
are third party verified by consumer lab
and they use the most proven flavonol
extract with over 20 years of research
including the landmark Cosmo study which
I'm going to link below they also
produce capsules if you prefer to take
your supplements like pills but if you
want to learn more about cocovia
products check out my link in the
description alright folks let's get into
it
foreign
like I thought we were collectively over
the trend of watching people consume a
large amount of forbidden foods that
they normally restrict in one day but
alas here we are another cheat day vlog
[Music]
yeah we're starting this day off good
we're starting with some greens I assume
she's referencing the fact that this is
a cheat day for her but that like the
greens powders in Jack's position is a
good or healthy choice I don't generally
love dichotomous language but I do get
what she's saying I actually have a
whole video on greens powders that you
can check out right here but in short I
don't have anything against consuming
greens powders if you enjoy them and
they're financially accessible to you I
think that ultimately they can be a
convenient way to fill in some
nutritional gaps and boost the
antioxidant intake in your day but I
really see these more as like a powdered
multivitamin not a replacement for fiber
rich vegetables and while they're often
advertised as being anti-bloating they
somehow contain a lot of ingredients
that can actually cause bloating in some
folks not to mention most the people who
consume greens powders are the ones who
definitely don't need them but if Lena
likes the ritual and she enjoys the
taste then great we love to see it so
I'm going to show you guys what I eat on
a weekend weekday Lena and weekend Lena
are two different Lenas okay I don't
count calories I'm not really strict
with my diet I just try to eat healthy
for the most part but when I'm craving
something or I want something I eat it
and I treat myself I eat good especially
on the weekends I'm letting loose you
guys probably know what I'm gonna say
about this let's hear it listen I think
it's totally normal for your diet to
look differently on a weekend than it
does on a weekday when on the weekend we
maybe have a little less structure or
routine to adhere to there may be more
social eating or different sleeping or
eating schedules and that all can mean
eating more calories than we usually do
that is healthy and normal but what I do
not think is very healthy is for your
diet to be so different that you feel
your identity as an eater is changed the
moment that Friday at five o'clock hits
usually if we need to have a cheat day
our typical diet during the week is
perhaps too strict so while I love that
Lena is giving herself mission to eat
the things that she craves generally we
don't need to kind of try to cram them
all into a cheat day if we give
ourselves permission to eat them
regularly during the week too saving
your calories or cravings for a weekend
is often a recipe for overeating or a
binge so if you are struggling with
black and white thinking I really
encourage you to challenge yourself to
weave some of these less nutritious
Cravings sporadically into the week and
see what changes psychologically for you
when the weekend hits for breakfast I'm
gonna have a bacon egg and cheese
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I mean I really don't know why we need
to label this a cheat meal like it looks
completely balanced to me and I think by
calling it that we're insinuating that
this is something that you should only
treat yourself to on occasion from my
perspective we got protein in the eggs
and the bacon fiber and healthy fats in
the avocado plus energizing morning
carbs in the bagel I don't really think
this is much different than her
non-cheat day locks and bagel with
scrambled eggs and fruit other than the
fact that one has a bit of bacon and the
other has some fruit obviously the
latter is a little bit more nutritious
but I certainly don't think it's worthy
of like a derogatory cheat day like
title nothing is really I do however
want to quickly talk about the
nitrate-free bacon which I know is often
marketed as a healthier alternative to
the cured conventional stuff I have no
issue with moderate consumption of any
kind of ultra processed Meats but it's
worth pointing out that these products
still do contain nitrates they just use
natural nitrates in celery salt as a
opposed to synthetic nitrates and we
don't actually have any quality research
to suggest that natural nitrates are
healthier than synthetic nitrates and on
top of that there is some concern that
natural bacon might even contain more
nitrates than the original stuff since
synthetic nitrate levels are capped but
natural levels are not either way I
don't think we need to demonize one
product over the other they're both
Ultra processed foods that should be
consumed in moderation which is why diet
variety over time is a lot more
important than any one food in your day
speaking of mango this has been my
latest Obsession lately sour strips this
is the tropical mango flavor I probably
shouldn't have this before I go for a
run but YOLO
I don't know I actually argue that the
fast acting sugar in these strips would
give her a good energy boost to help
fuel her cardio sesh but even so like
one mango strip only provides like five
grams of sugar and 30 calories which is
pretty negligible if we're talking
pre-workout fuel so if she likes them
and they sound amazing I say go for it
so while I'm waiting for that to heat up
I'm gonna have some jalapeno chips I
don't know if it's just me but I'm so
impatient and so when food is cooking or
warming up I need to eat something while
waiting or else I'm gonna go crazy
jalapeno chips are fire literally I got
my lunch this is shrimp Biryani can you
just see how delicious this looks those
of you who know me I am not the best
cook okay but also when I go grocery
shopping I notice that a lot of the food
that I get goes to waste because I'm
only one person and I can only eat so
much so it's been nice having these
cookie knitty meals just on hand
honestly the frozen microwave dinner has
come a long way since the old hungry man
days
with a full pound of meat and potatoes
you can eat like a man and be full like
a man and this one specifically has a
whopping 43 grams of protein and a good
amount of calories and carbs and I also
like that it uses a lot of Whole Foods
and spices with little to no additives
so for folks like Lena who are conscious
of food waste and maybe need something
that's super convenient flavorful fast
and nutritionally sound I think this is
a great choice again I'm not really
understanding how or why this should be
thought of as like a cheat meal it looks
really similar to her non-cheet day
fried rice that she makes herself now
I'm headed to dinner with my boyfriend
we are getting one of my favorite things
to eat which is boil
we are here at the boil
[Music]
love me a good seafood boil so this
sounds like an awesome dinner and also
inherently nutrient dense lobster and
shrimp are both super high protein lower
fat Seafood options so even with the
side of fries in there I actually
consider this to be a relatively light
and balanced meal a delicious option
when you're eating out we're walking off
this seafood boil my stomach right now I
gotta unbutton my pants we're walking
though to get some dessert
[Music]
holy [ __ ] that looks good especially
that pretzel cookie looking thing with
the ice cream and the chocolate sauce
that is my style of course any date
night is just like not complete without
a little dessert and I'm all forgetting
dessert but I just hope that she isn't
eating to the point of discomfort and
feeling the need to like cram in three
desserts just because it's her official
day off or cheat day honestly I actually
think that Lena's day of eating is
really inherently balanced and only
seems to differ from her usual routine
and that she maybe has some chips and
some fries and a few desserts it's
certainly a huge relief coming from
watching a bunch of more extreme cheat
day videos that we see on this channel
where craters are sitting down to eat an
entire box of donuts then a massive
Pizza a ton of candy Wings pasta and
more but language is very important and
just wonder if we were to maybe drop the
label of cheat day if we would be better
able to enjoy our meal and dessert in
portions that don't make us feel
uncomfortably full before the whole
weekday Lena diet starts back up again
on Monday and I got my popcorn with
sprinkle of truffle salt I was craving
something salty after that heavy dessert
I'm also going to eat a banana with like
a little bit of peanut butter because I
just realized that I have not had a
single fruit this entire day so I feel
like I should have a little fruit or
something you know for the health this
snack looks like a delicious under
crushing combo and assuming she wasn't
uncomfortably full from the dinner and
dessert I'm really glad that she honored
her body's desire for something salty
and also some fruit I used to struggle a
lot with binge eating starving myself
crazy body dysmorphia and just feeling
overall really insecure I would go days
where I would try to starve myself and
other days where I would just binge
everything I see and all because I
wanted to look a certain way the minute
I stopped nitpicking everything about my
body counting every single calorie and
restricting myself that is when I
actually started seeing noticeable
differences in my physique but more
importantly my mental health but I
really want to emphasize that balance is
so important eat healthy because it's
good for you but also eat what you want
because that's also good for you it's
good for your mental health and your
sanity you gotta enjoy your life and
you're not going to enjoy it if you're
consistently restricting yourself and
stressing about the way that you look
okay I have a few quick things I want to
say here first of all I think this is an
amazing testimony of everything that you
have to gain when you let go of dieting
and restriction the diet mentality is
notorious for convincing us that our
worth and value comes down to our size
but no amount of weight loss will
satisfy you when you're deeply
entrenched in the comparative hell of
diet culture comparison really is the
thief of joy and dye culture will never
let us be happy but when we learn to let
go of rules restrictions and Obsession
it frees up so much mental space and
gives us the freedom to dedicate our
energy to things that actually do make
us happy I'm also relieved that Lena is
in in a better place with her own
relationship with food and I also agree
that balance is so important health is
not just about physical lab values but
it's also about emotional and social
well-being as well so there can be
multiple reasons that we choose to eat
something and none of them should ever
be considered bad reasons having said
all that I do believe that promoting
cheat days is promoting dye culture this
is not the same as balance where all
foods fit because the mere idea of a
cheat day means that you are
deliberately restricting or dieting
every other day and that you only give
yourself permission to eat the things
that you crave or want on that one
special day and again Lena's cheat day
is in no way extreme the mere use of the
label is often enough to create scarcity
mentality that can trigger overeating in
a Last Supper style eating episode so I
acknowledge that everyone is on a
journey and that journey is never black
and white or linear but I just don't
want people walking away from this video
thinking not having a cheat day routine
is best practice in healing your
relationship with food and on that note
that's all that I have for you guys
today I would love to hear your thoughts
on this whole cheat day trend don't
forget to give this video the thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]